they gave me these this this this list
of 84 charges they wanted to arrest me
for because they made each separate hack
a charge right if you want to charge it
84 times they have to arrest you 84
times and then that means they have to
question you eight or four times but
they only did it for half the charges
for 40 of the charges because they could
only hold me for 24 hours so the time
run out
yeah because they'd arrested you too
much
[Music]
okay so Mustafa obviously we've met you
before uh we've done a video previously
together but for anyone that doesn't
know who you are or a new a new listener
or a new Watcher um could you introduce
yourself and explain what you're known
for sure so um when I was about 15 16 I
was involved with a hacking group that
hacked into various you know
governmental and corporate organizations
and I was arrested for it and that's one
of the things that I'm known for and I
think what we'll do straight away now is
get into that in a lot more detail and
but just going back to the beginning can
you tell me what your childhood was like
sure so I was actually born in Baghdad
in Iraq and we moved to the UK to London
about the year 2000 and I lived in
southeast London in Peckham in the
Council of that it was a it was a fairly
deprived area I kind of just very
naturally became interested in computers
like my dad bought a computer and I
spent a lot of time on it at first it
was kind of like playing online games
but then I started becoming more
interested in the technical side of it
as well in programming
it's quite like so how old were you here
I moved to the UK when I was six yeah
and so I started like playing around
with computers when I was very early
very young when I was 708. okay and did
you seek out other groups of people that
were doing the same thing at this age
sort of eight or nine still very young
or was it something that you're just
doing at home is next to your schoolwork
and stuff like that no it was just
something I was doing my own I didn't
really have any friends that did it
and like all the people that I knew were
online but they were older than me as
well you couldn't tell I'm eight or nine
year old online like
um it's just text right as long as you
have good grammar you can't really tell
like you're you're a kid that probably
would have been quite surprised if they
realized they were interacting with an
eight-year-old yeah
how so how did you start interacting
with other people that were doing things
under the banner of anonymous before I
came I kind of joined Anonymous or
became part of the movement I
um was involved in this online chat room
that was focused around internet
activism some some something called the
internet Forum or something like that
which was like a cabal of companies
trying to make the internet that's free
and you know people were discussing how
do we purchase against that and they
were saying they were saying let's do
things like petitions or websites to
inform people
and then but then there was someone in
the chat room saying let's actually try
and do something illegal to launch
what's called a denial of service attack
to the company supporting this the
denial of service attack is basically
kind of like a attack that you would do
against a company or a website to shut
it down you basically flood that website
with so much traffic or so much requests
that it becomes overloaded and shuts
down it's kind of like a kind of like an
online version of a physical sitting you
know like back in the back in the 40s or
50s in America you know black people
were
um doing physical settings in
restaurants to protest you know racism
this is kind of like a more benign
version of that like online online
version you know for example one
Anonymous
um
did the denial of service attack against
PayPal and MasterCard and Wikileaks that
was to protest them denying access to
WikiLeaks they were blocking donations
to Big colleagues I kind of realized
that hacking could actually be a
powerful tool
to kind of expose wrongdoing or to kind
of shift power away from people or to
express people in power and how old were
you say you were here
I think I was just like
um maybe 13 or 14. so from an early an
early age did you have this sense of
moral obligation towards hacking yes I
think I started developing that when I
was a teenager you ended up setting up
your own uh group didn't you is it okay
to call my group I don't want to use it
as a group is a group okay can we can
you talk us through a little SEC and
what that was so I was like
um unlike Anonymous was a private group
it wasn't like any it wasn't like
something that anyone can claim to be
one of the major hacks we did was a U.S
military contractor called HP Gary
Federal
you know we leaked 70 000 emails from
them because they were threatening to
kind of expose
in their own words the leaders of
anonymous American Military contractors
you would have imagined they'd have some
of the best security yeah that not
really they were a cyber security
company so you thought they would have
good security and the CEO
um used the same password everywhere
like use the same password for his
Paypal account
as he did for his World of Warcraft
account and so that allows us to gain
access to all of his accounts so uh had
you wanted to uh would you have been
able to take control of his Paypal
account you know from from the finances
in there could you have withdrawn money
or sent money elsewhere had you wanted
to yeah definitely someone in the group
actually you know whacked his iPad
remotely because we were able to log
into his Apple account I mean I'm quite
bad for having various diff like the
same password in lots of places but
you'd think somebody in control of that
kind of a company might have been a bit
more cloged up yeah for sure well I
guess he's probably got quite a a bit of
resentment towards littlesec these days
yeah
um but we follow each other on Twitter
now
I think he did come to London once and
kind of meet with
um another hacker in that was in the
group as well oh so no hard feelings
were there any other uh major events or
major hacks during a time at law SEC
that you can remember
we hacked Sony seven times for example
seven times yeah like what did they do
to you
Sony was interesting because
um they were kind of like a classic
hacker Target there wasn't specifically
one thing that they did wrong it was
like a series of things for example they
injected like malware to music CD-ROMs
that would take over your computer to
prevent you from copying that music
right you post copyright and at the time
they were suing this hacker Who had who
managed to jailbreak the PlayStation 3 I
think called geohot so they were kind of
like a very anti-hacker of natural kind
of Target
and you know during the summer of 2011 I
think they were hacked you know 23 times
uh seven of them was us and then there
was this other guy who hacked them like
six times so it was kind of like a
competition to see who could hacking the
most between us and this other guy that
was also hacking them quite a lot and
what were you doing to them with the
hacks it was like various things like
because Sony's quite a big organization
so
they had different many different
businesses so we for example you know we
hacked uh certain like a certain music
website I think
um we had like the PlayStation developer
website
those you know various various different
hacks various databases usernames and
passwords and were you was your purpose
to make them look stupid or to just slow
them down or to cause them a little bit
of time and money what was it what were
you kind of hoping to achieve with the
hacks a bit of a mix really and a lot of
it was actually they weren't taking
security seriously it's like if you
would email them if we discovered the
text and we just emailed them to say hey
you've got an issue they won't take it
seriously
so like the only way to take it
seriously is that they actually get
hacked and it creates a press disaster
for them only only then to say okay
we're losing confidence in our customers
because they've seen that we've been
hacked so many times only then do they
take security seriously let's get into
leading up to your arrest then can you
sort of tell us how that happens at this
point just before you're arrested are
you starting to
sense anything are you feeling
nervous about anything are you feeling
like people are looking for you or are
you just business as normal getting on
with your life yeah I mean things
definitely did feel hot because I think
a few weeks before I was arrested
there's another guy in the UK that was
arrested
his name was Ryan he wasn't directly
involved he wasn't directly a profile
group but he was associated with us he
runs some of our chat rooms
and so it definitely felt they were onto
us to some extent before I was arrested
I actually decided to quit
not necessarily because I thought I'd be
arrested but because I wanted to kind of
move on with my life it just became
a bit boring to some extent and how old
are you at this point 16 16 right okay
and a part of it was kind of this at one
point we became so popular that we
weren't doing any hacks ourselves
anymore it was just other hackers
sending us hacks sending sending us
leaks to to to publish they became more
like a publishing
um kind of group boiler hacking group
and one of the things that we were also
publish was this
uh documents from the Arizona Police
Department was called Arizona Department
of Public Safety because there was this
police officer that just used the
password one two three four five six so
this
guy called Jeremy Hammond managed to
hack into it download all the emails and
he would give he would give me a press
release
to
um put with the leak and I think we
immediately I just posted it
and part of the press released says
something like uh off the pigs and it
was like you know that's like kill cops
and you know I didn't really read that I
just posted it and I thought you know
that was it it's going a bit far
um I'm not necessarily a fan of cops
myself but I don't want to publish
something that says kill cops
necessarily
um okay so so it was feeling a little
bit hot the guy from your group had just
been arrested so then how does it
progress onto uh your arrest
trying to remember if I was the first
person that I was arrested or the second
person well actually I wasn't the first
person I was the second person because
there was actually someone in the US was
arrested but he was he was an informant
so we didn't know he was arrested and no
one knew that he was arrested okay he
became an informant after he was
arrested so they flipped him yeah they
flipped him okay so how long had he been
an informant within your group before
you were arrested like a few months like
two or three months so they'd arrested
him in America and they'd basically
presumably threatened him with quite a
substantial prison sentence unless he
kind of started to give them more people
in the UK yeah because he was you know
in his 30s and he had children to look
after her so he really didn't want to go
to jail so he kind of flipped wow during
that period was he trying to find out
more information about you as a person
to find out who you were or was he just
reporting on the regular chat you guys
would be having well I mean he he would
claim that he wasn't trying to reveal
information from us but you know I've
looked into the FBI in documents and
well well apparently what he says is
that the FBI just asked him to
um continue as normal except that they
would install some piece of software on
his computer
to capture all the chat logs that people
were talking about
you know that's what he claims he just
says like okay I didn't actually
try to actively
get you to reveal information I was very
careful not to reveal any personal
information but it's but when she's
talking to people you know when you're
talking to people they were like family
you were talking to them all the time
like uh you're talking hours on day to
like three a.m in the morning so there's
always a chance of you know some
information that is revealed about your
life that could allow law enforcement to
um kind of catch you you know like for
example with the Jeremy Hammond case
which is the guy that gave us the
Arizona Police Department he was caught
because he revealed in the chat room
that he was arrested before and he's
currently in drop I think like drug
rehabilitation or something like that
and so that now that narrows it down
massively because the FBI could just
look at okay he was being arrested
before and who's currently in drug
rehabilitation and that narrows it down
massively for them
yeah so as I was saying you know I was
arrested I was the first person to be
arrested that was publicly known to be
arrested but I was the second person to
be arrested in the group
you know I was 16 it was this was back
in 2011. it was actually just after I
finished My GCSE exams which was really
convenient because if there before I
finished my exams then I might have
missed some exams
but it was like a few weeks after
they kind of knocked on the door and
what time of day was it uh I think I
don't know I think it was like 10 a.m
maybe so right it wasn't too early in
the morning as I said before I already
quit the group actually and so I
and I bought a new laptop as well so my
old laptop with all the evidence that
you know was thrown away and the hard
drive was smashed into a million pieces
so there was nothing they could get on
that so I just had like a fresh laptop
for the most part so they opened the
door uh I think my little brother let
them in
you know it wasn't it was just like a
typical knock on the door but there was
something suspicious about it
uh that made me wanna
turn off my laptop so I did and so they
came in and I think they immediately
knew that I they were looking for me
and so they came into the bedroom and
they searched a whole bedroom they took
any electrical devices
through all clothes all the wardrobes
and so on and so forth to find evidence
and so I was just sitting there in the
bedroom for two hours watching them do
this and they were trying to talk to me
to kind of say
to reveal information or to try to
verify it's me but I would usually just
say
I need to talk to a lawyer first which
is quite Forward Thinking for 16 year
old yeah but I think I read a line yeah
I think people were talking about it
we're just going to take a quick break
from this episode to talk about a
sponsor and that is nordvpn uh Conor one
of the show's producers with me here you
already use Nord I believe yeah I do
yeah Ben um as you know with this job we
travel a lot which means going to hotels
or coffee shops restaurants log on to
public Wi-Fi so that we can work the
risk with that is it can harm your data
and your security and your privacy with
no VPN turned on no that absolutely
protects you from logging on to any
public network it keeps all your data
safe fantastic and you've been using it
for a while I believe yeah originally
again it was mainly for travel
um again with this job we might go from
City to City Country to Country it's
great for booking hotel rooms at
discounted rates because you can
virtually change your location which
means for example if you're booking a
hotel in the UK but you're in the USA
you can log on to a UK website to get
the local rates fantastic there's loads
more benefits to nodvpn and it's all for
the price of a cup of coffee a month
extraordinary lives listeners can head
over to nordvpn.com
minutes for a 20 discount on their sign
up and four additional months absolutely
free that's nordvpn.com minutes
and were you scared at this point
I don't think I was scared specifically
I was more annoyed or pissed off okay
because I knew like they wouldn't send
me the gel because I was a minor and at
the time in the UK no Miner has been
sent to jail
under the computer Mysteries Act
that's changed
recently there was one case where it has
been the case but at the time it hasn't
okay and at this point like all your
family are they like
they presumably have no idea what you do
in your spare time with the computer so
are they all just kind of like what the
hell's going on yeah I think the just
what I would play games on the computer
yeah I think they didn't know I was
programming but they didn't know I was
doing any hacking yeah and um yeah that
must have been quite a shock for them I
suppose because it's almost like a dual
identity going on when someone says to
them oh this guy's been hacking several
high profile targets all around the
world yeah yeah it was definitely
unexpected for them uh I think like my
Dad we were shocked and my mom
she doesn't know anything about
computers she doesn't even know what any
of this means and so they they got you
and then did they leave you in your um
did they leave you in your house at that
point or did they did they arrest you at
that point and take you with them so
they took me with them
um to Belgravia police station to be
interviewed
and so I got a lawyer uh it came
and you know we sat down in an interview
and I was advised by a lawyer and they
came up they kept me overnight by the
way uh because entity was the next
morning so I had to sleep in the police
cell overnight they gave me these this
this this list of 84 charges
they wanted to arrest me for because
they made each separate hack a charge
right and so there were 84 charges for
like 84 different violations of the
computer misuse hacked for every single
you know hack we did I I was advised by
my lawyer to give a no comment interview
which means I should reply no comment to
every question
and they were very annoyed by that
um
they said you know you should talk to us
you know because we can help maybe
you'll get a linear more linear sentence
and they were also trying to threaten me
to say the FBI might extradite you to
the US if you can incorporate so they
were they were very annoyed and it was a
very strange interview because if they
want to charge you 84 times they have to
arrest you 84 times and then that means
they have to caution you 84 times
so they had to caution me for every
single charge and they said you know
when when they say
you know you are not under arrest
uh you do not have to say anything but
if you don't say anything it may harm
your defense
they had to say that for every charge
but they but they only did it for half
the charges for 40 of the charges
because
um I think what happened was
they could only hold me for 24 hours so
the time ran out
yeah because they'd arrested you too
much yeah exactly I mean that must have
been an intimidating thing though to see
84 different charges at 16. I mean you
must there must have been a sense of
when they were saying we could extradite
you did you believe that I thought that
was a risk but it seemed unlikely like
are they gonna extradite a teenager it's
pretty unlikely okay so you've got the
you've got these um massive amount of
charges
to make presumably to make them stick
they had to prove you with tea flow yeah
because that's who they were trying to
arrest right yeah because their main
evidence was the chat logs and you know
the chat log it says tether said this
teeth like that and they were going
through a chat law saying what did you
mean by this what does that mean
and their whole premise was that I was
stiffer so they had to somehow link me
until
didn't really provide any evidence I
would see through actually
it was just assumed I was Seether my
suspicion was that uh like gchg wasn't
involved so just hears Hugh
is stands for government communication
headquarters which is the spy agency in
Cheltenham uh what we what would what
Snowden discovered back in 2011 was the
gchq was actively targeting anonymous
and one of the ways that they would
discover
people Anonymous is that they would send
them like this a link
to a news story or something for example
in one case they sent someone a link to
BBC news story
through something called the a URL
shortener like but they had their own
URL shortener so you click you would
click it and they would see your IP
address and then they could see okay
like a subpoena they
internet service provider to get your
real name or your real address and so
that's what I suspect happened and they
didn't want to say that in the actual
court case because that's a matter of if
they reveal how they quote me that
that's like a matter of National
Security because they're revealing the
the Spy techniques and do you think they
were surprised because presumably when
they turned up to your house they were
going right we're arresting this guy if
some pretty serious hacking offenses 84
different arrests go to the house and
it's a 16 year old kid do you think they
were surprised by that or do you think
they already sort of knew who you were
well I I think they must have known who
ours was because
I don't think they would have just came
to my house they might they must have
done some kind of like in person
surveillance or something like that or
more investigation hmm
what happens next
I was released on bail
after 24 hours
and I wasn't charged with anything at
the time because they needed more
evidence because I gave them a no
comment interview
what they did not actually charge me
with computer misuse act what they
charged me was with criminal conspiracy
you don't have to actually charge them
with the crime itself you can charge
them with conspiring to commit that
crime
so and that's a much easier charge to
prove because you don't have to prove
they actually did that crime did you
have to prove that they talked about
doing that crime or they plan to do that
crime they conspire through that crime
and they had the evidence of that in the
chat in the chat logs eventually
um there's still those 84 charges the
two charges to two conspiracy charges
actually it was originally four charges
two of them were fraud charges
uh which were eventually dropped because
obviously there was we weren't doing
fraud like there was no Financial
incentive so where'd they come from a
misunderstanding or um I think well it
was very kind of vague it was like we
hacked into credit card information or
something like that it was like are
there calls that could be used for fraud
but we didn't actually do any food with
it right so it was kind of like a very
it was very it was very vague so they
dropped it
one of the companies that we were
accused of hacking was this company
called um
I think it was like something like
blackberg security or something it was
like a U.S company
they weren't actually hacked by us they
were they just pretended to be hacked by
us and we paid along with it because it
was like it was just like kind of like a
challenge to them or like a way to get
pressed for them yes okay yeah I bet you
regretted that in the end well I don't
think it made a difference
but it was all included in the
um
uh legal charges right you manage not to
serve any jail time am I right in
thinking that yeah there were four
codependence in the case
one of them was the person I already
mentioned and Ryan who was kind of in
our Inner Circle but not the six Common
People two other people so three in
total including me
where the three were part of the six
core people
so it turned out like out of six people
three of them were in the UK oh wow I
know no one knew that and you didn't
know that either you know that yeah wow
so it was kind of like this huge uh
coincidence
yeah so we were all in court together
um in the docks with four people we
never talked to each other we just
talked to each other online the first
time we met was in court that must have
been weird because you said earlier when
you're chatting that they were like
family at that point talking to them to
2 A.M 3 A.M yeah and then the first time
you actually see each other is must have
been like oh you look like that I look
like this yeah exactly well I've seen
pictures of them online right after they
were arrested yeah right we're just
going to take a quick break from this
episode to talk about a sponsor of the
show which is better help better help is
an online therapy and counseling service
which matches clients with
professionally trained therapists I'm
joined by Brian ear producer of the show
I believe you yourself have tried
therapists and counselors yes I have
over the years I've actually tried and
met a few different therapists over the
years and I think one of the things
that's really amazing about betterhelp
is that you can find the person that
fits you best and I think that's really
important especially when you're talking
about you know life challenges you want
to be chatting to someone who really
gets you and I think that's an amazing
thing that better help us to offer yeah
I think for me there's that social
awkwardness about once you've found
someone if it's in person
feel like you're not clicking that sense
of saying I don't really want to come
back just feels kind of horrible whereas
if it's all done virtually I suppose it
makes it easier yeah absolutely and I
think better help is also really
affordable in comparison to perhaps
private therapy or having to wait on
waiting lists so I think having the
option to find the right person and it's
affordable makes it like a really
appealing option for therapy as the
world's largest therapy service better
help us match three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus as
brownie says it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 of your first month at
betterhelp.com minutes with that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash minutes with yeah so
your sentence we all pled guilty because
the evidence was overwhelming especially
given that there was an informant in the
US
yeah because I was under 18 I didn't get
a custodial sentence
so I don't have to serve any jail time
I had What's called the suspended
sentence so I had 24 months jail
sentence suspended for I think 20 months
or all the way around which means that I
don't have to serve the time unless I
commit another crime
and then I was also sentenced to um 320
hours of community service and the other
guys today go to prison
two of the guys didn't really serve
partial time because in the UK you only
have to serve half of your sentence in
jail and other half is on probation and
also they were on electronic tag every
day your own electronic tag counts to
half a day off your job sentence
so I think like one of them only had to
spend a month in jail and another one
had to spend a few more months okay but
some one of the persons one of the
people Ryan had to spend like a year or
more in jail but that's because he broke
his Bell conditions
uh because he wasn't supposed to use the
internet right and then so he was
arrested
uh for breaching his Bell conditions and
so you said so there was six car members
three of you in the UK and then one that
was flipped by an informant and then one
was the Ryan guy is this right yeah and
the other there was one guy that was in
court okay called AV unit and not to
this day no one knows who he is wow but
he's he's still like we chat to him on
Twitter
you know he's still like online on
Twitter he doesn't hack anymore but he's
like he's still got through with her
account and occasionally like he pops up
but he's never he's never been arrested
wow so he was the only one so his
security must have been incredible if he
was the only one of that whole group
that managed to evade it or in a country
where they couldn't yeah didn't have a
partnership Maybe
okay so when you make the other
defendants in car what was the age split
like were they all similar to you like
16 or were they I mean you've said you
were the youngest but what were their
sort of Ages like
um yeah like I think we're all on 21
when we did the hacking so we were all
there very young I was the youngest the
oldest I think was someone
I think it was 25 he was like x-move I
think he might have been ex-militatory
or something like that well 25. and he
was actually someone who was pretending
to be a girl the whole time so everyone
thought he was a girl oh my god really
yeah so the whole time you thought there
was a girl in the group and you got into
court and it was next military guy yeah
I'm not sure how many people actually
believe that was a girl because like the
way that he was communicating was over
the top like he was smiley faces all the
time so it's like and stuff like that to
pretend to be a girl so it's like this
is probably someone pretending to be a
girl not an actual and do you think that
was just to be an extra level of
anonymity yeah I mean that's what he
says he's like extra security wow he's
not like he's not transsexual or
anything like that he's like a very
straight ex-military person but he was
planning to be a girl online at what
point did you learn that um one of your
car group had been an informant
it was I know like a I think a year
after I was arrested
um
it was kind of revealed to us it was a
view of the lawyer as they presented new
evidence in the case
and how did that feel
I don't really feel anything
specifically about it like if I only
learned about it
after I was arrested I might have been
more pissed off but it was like a year
later if I then had to have moved on
with my life so it wasn't you know that
uh shocking to me or like it wasn't it
didn't piss me off that much but since
then he's been back online
and he doesn't have any like remorse for
it and that pisses me off more because
he put people in jail and not just us
but he put like innocent not innocent
people but he entrapped people so there
was other people in the US he would kind
of tell them hey you should hack this or
here's a link to some vulnerable server
because you should go and hack them so
like he was actually actively telling
the kids to hack stuff and then
Gathering evidence on that
and then putting them in jail and he
doesn't he's got no remorse on that he
doesn't feel he did anything wrong at
all are you still friends with the other
members yeah we're still friends
um with all other members and we talk
occasionally except for the mystery guy
that escaped yeah I mean he's still on
Twitter like yeah something once a year
yeah once again okay and then what so
what was so you served your time in a in
a shop but um am I right in thinking
that part of your sentence was that you
weren't allowed to access the internet
so that wasn't part of my sentence that
was part of my bell conditions right in
case I go online to try and complete
more crimes or to try and delete
Eminence or try to get back in touch
with other members of my group I see so
once your bail was up you were allowed
to re-access the internet have computers
all that sort of stuff yeah okay and do
they do anything with you like do they
monitor you in a specific way afterwards
or anything like that or are you free to
just go back to your life so we had
something called a serious crime
prevention order
something that imposed on serious
criminals and not just hackers but it
might be like credit card forces or like
you know pedophiles or sexual abusers
and part of the serious crime
professional order meant that
you know every time I buy a computer I
have to inform The Police Every time I
dispose a computer
of the implicit police inform the police
and one of the conditions was that I was
not allowed to delete my internet
browser history
but they never said I couldn't use a
private browsing mode so that was an
easy way around it okay
okay yeah right I have to create it I
have to create bro they said that I
can't delete mindset Bible History but
they never said that
I have to create ethernet browser
history yeah so it must be quite tricky
for them when they're setting these
rules out because unless they have
someone who's really deep in that world
like yourself they'll always be a way to
interpret the words in a different way
or like you say get away around it well
initially they try to impose a condition
that said like every time I use the
cloud I had to inform them and yeah what
does that mean what does a cloud mean
what does it mean every time I use the
cloud
um so we challenged him on that and they
removed that what did they mean I don't
I don't think they knew what the cloud
meant I think but maybe they meant like
if I was to use a server
uh if I was to set up online server or
something like that
they wanted to know about it you're all
quite young guys and you said that
previous to this there hadn't been much
of a history of arrests for sort of
computer-based defenses in this world
like hacking
yes yes yes
um there'd been a big period where there
hadn't been much and that had given you
a sense of security in terms of like
people aren't really getting arrested
for doing this stuff yeah do you think
that you've just done too much to the
point where they were like we need to
make an example of this group because
it's it's normalizing this activity or
do you think you did one specific thing
that triggered a chain of events why do
you think you LOL SEC were made such an
example of
um well I mean we hadn't a lot of
government organizations like we we
launched a denial of service detect
against the CIA we took the CIA website
offline
and even though that didn't really cause
any damage that was very embarrassing to
the US government you know we leave
information from the pentagram service
for example
um so yeah it was very embarrassing to
the US government so they wanted to
investigate this you know when you think
about people who get into this world do
you see a big distinction between
reasons for doing it did you ever come
across people in your travels through
that kind of area of the internet who
you could see were trying to do it for
malicious reasons there's many different
reasons for why people might hack uh
that spans the whole range of human
motivation like ultimately it's a tool
right so you might do it for financial
gain you might just want to cause chaos
unless what world burn you might want to
do it use it as activism
it's a neutral tool that you can use it
for positive or bad now the internet can
be used for positive and negative but
for me I was I saw it as a tool to
redistribute power
uh from where power is concentrated back
to the masses
through things like leaking information
and because I realized that information
is a very powerful tool
um that can level the playing field
between you know citizens and large
corporations and governments
and what about now what do you do now
um so since I was arrested I I did a
computer science degree in University in
University
and then I did a PhD
focusing on scaling cryptocurrencies and
blockchain Technology
and now I run my own kind of blockchain
project
and do you miss the hacking
I want to say I miss it specifically
I was just say it was you know it was a
it was fun
but I wouldn't want to do it again uh
because I think I've moved on past that
there's a it's interesting because I
feel like there was a burst of media
around hackers
um especially about Anonymous it felt
like there was a lot of stuff on TV
about Anonymous marches and anonymous
hacks I feel like that's died down a lot
in recent years do you think that's
because the media are less interested or
do you feel like less people are doing
it
I don't think there's this hackers
there's still activism going on
uh but not necessarily so much under the
banner Anonymous this like it's not
completed there's still like some
hackers under the banner Anonymous or
loltec in like I think parts of Asia and
Latin America
but not so much in the English speaking
world
and two two comments uh that I thought
were interesting from the previous video
we did together uh in the comments
section uh one of them was there was
quite a few people said this guy should
be running in uh internet security
business have you never considered that
um
well that's quite a common select
stereotype like for hackers like they
should after they're arrested is very
common for them to work for
Internet Security uh companies or become
a white hat hacker and that's what a lot
of people are arrested in law cycle
Anonymous have done
but I was more interested in the
creativity side of it I was interested
in programming
and trying to create something or kind
of research and that's why I did a PhD
and that's why I've started my own
kind of company there's obviously a
stereotype about hackers that in TV and
films and stuff that they're kind of
loners don't interact with people very
well don't like speaking to people like
staying alone in their bedroom but
throughout this whole conversation like
there's a thread through which your
motivation always seems to be to help
the masses in your own words
redistributing power or authority back
to the masses where do you think that's
come from with you
so I guess I but also many other hackers
kind of believe in a world that's based
on Merit
rather than a status or welfare power
like if you have a good idea or you're
skilled you should be able to do
something based on the Merit
you know before blockchain technology
it's been very difficult to organize
large groups of people for example for a
activist purpose for example there's
something called
Assange Dao and Assange Dao was this
thing that raised 50 million dollars to
put a legal defense campaign of Julian
Assange
and you know tens of thousands of people
participate in that in a completely
decentralized way without using some
centralized you know service like
Kickstarter or something like that
which might have not been possible in
the first place because remember a
PayPal Mastercard in the Visa block
donations to weeklies
and so by eliminating you know middlemen
like Paypal Mastercard Visa it allowed
Wikileaks to
raise money without going through these
corrupts or untrustworthy fat bodies and
the final thing I was just going to end
on is one of the one of the most common
comments on the video we did with you
before is this guy is a real life Mr
Robot have you ever heard that before
yeah I mean people say that I look like
Mr Robot even though I don't because
he's Egyptian so we're both Arabic
the interesting thing about Mr Robot is
one of the consultants for Mr Robot was
this guy called Greg hoosh which was
part of anonymous and he helped to
consult on the characters so that that
Mr Robot
um the the main hacker Elliot is kind of
based on a mix of different hackers no
there's no hacker in specific but he's
kind of like meant to be like uh an
average of different hackers and was the
would is it a more realistic type of
hacking that you see in that show or is
it still kind of fantasy yeah Mr Robot
they're hacking and Mr Robot is
definitely very accurate oh they
actually hired uh hackers to come up
with new hacks and exploits to use them
in the show wow like everything you see
there is actually real exploits that you
can do great all right look thanks so
much for coming back and thanks for your
time Mustafa it's really fascinating to
hear your story and
um it's an area of the world I think
that everyone sort of knows exists but
doesn't know much about it so it's great
to be able to sit with someone who can
explain it so eloquently so thanks again
thanks for having me cheers so once we
were in I sneak out in Haze and just put
a sign on the door saying please do not
close this door and just wait for
someone to come and see the sign and go
oh that's a rule and that so as soon as
the guy comes out there's a few people
will pass it but the guy came out saw
the sign and wedged the door open and
then I could get